last time on true fear I talked about
how I pretty much almost died on the
subway you haven't seen that one I will
take pity on you leave you a link so you
can go check it out as I mentioned the
last one I live in LA now but I'm a
Chicago guy who loves my Cubs for those
of you who don't know Harry Caray is one
of the most legendary Cubs TV
broadcasters in the 80s and 90s to the
point where he's become an icon in fact
the stadium now has video board upon
which they frequently have Harry lead
the seventh-inning stretch at Wrigley
for some reason pretty much all Chicago
sports legends have their own steakhouse
we've got Walter Payton's round house
Ditka's restaurant Michael Jordan's
steak house and of course Harry Caray's
Italian steakhouse
which is where today's story begins
shall we dig right in sorry for that ton
so the year is 2012 and I just graduated
from high school it was August so that
summer was winding down and some of us
were on the way to college in a couple
of week so we wanted to go out together
for one last dinner and we had never
really been anywhere nice before so we
thought it would be cool to hit up the
legendary Harry Caray at the front of
this restaurant there's this bust of the
man himself and on the wall you see all
the pictures of celebrities who have
been to the restaurant posing in front
of it we decided to go get a group photo
around it so that was it we take the
photo
get out of there go home okay but
there's more at some point the photo
gets uploaded onto Facebook right eight
days later one of the guys will just
call him chic leaves the following
comment hey Roman is that your hand on
my left shoulder because it looks like
translucent to which he replied I
honestly don't know
if that's my hand haha Sheik replies
doesn't it look a little strange though
it's like transparent then I noticed an
interesting detail there's a ring on it
it isn't any of us we're all 18 at that
point and none of us are married plus
just look at us clearly in front of us
are married ok I'm done I'm done then
Roman brings up that it could be like a
class ring but
his hand is straight down by his side
and you can clearly tell by the angle of
where he is that you would see his wrist
if it was him the next comment reads if
I had to guess it looks kind of like mr.
boat houses or the floating hand from
the Addams Family well first of all dude
it's called The Addams Family not Addams
Family and second of all the possibility
of it being mr. boat houses hand is
probably the most likely explanation at
this point but I honestly don't believe
that it's him based on the distance and
the angle of the hand even if he was
able to reach that far his hand would be
more pointed to the left-hand side of
the photo plus something comes up later
to prove that it wasn't him I'll get
back to that this guy thinks that it's
sailors hand but that doesn't make sense
so I say Baylor's hands are on Roman
left shoulder and mr. boat houses right
shoulder it can be bailing so his next
suggestion reiterates the possibility
that mr. boat hasn't had that's when she
crevalle how he first noticed the
mysterious hand he rides this it's not
he's the one who noticed and questioned
the hand on my shoulder knee so
basically that's not any of our hands my
hands both seemed to be in my pocket and
besides it's only in my left hand that's
concealed and that's a right hand on
cheek shoulder so I came up with the
theory that the ghost of Harry Caray
wanted to get in on our group photo this
was 2012 and it was worst Cubs season in
over 40 years they lost over a hundred
games that year so it makes sense that
Harry's ghost would be especially
Restless it's also been said that in
Game seven of the World Series in 2016
when the Cubs gave up the lead and lost
all their momentum going into extra
innings that it was the spirits Harry
Carey Ernie Banks and Ron Santo that
came together to cause the rain delay
that give the team time to recuperate
and come out swinging with everything on
the line in the time if you found the
story entertaining and be willing to go
ahead and drop me a like on this video
that would be much appreciated be sure
to leave your own Theory down in the
comments for the next true fear I'll
probably do a follow-up to that video on
the hobo King let me know if you guys
still want to see that I've been talking
to some different people who have their
own stories about creepy stuff going
down in that apartment complex and they
said that they'd be willing to come on
the show and talk about it so be sure to
subscribe to Susie's world for new
or every week ring that death bell for
notifications and yeah I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive
[Music]